A man is sitting in a chair inside a containment
cell at the SCP Foundation.
The man is dressed normally and he isn’t
trying to escape or attack the researchers
who are observing him.
The only thing that makes this man different
from you or I is that he ages right in front
of us, going from a teenager to an old man
in a matter of minutes.
At first glance, SCP-1007 looks very normal,
just a corpse lying in a standard coffin.
Well, the corpse of an old man in a coffin
being kept locked up in a containment chamber
is normal when compared to some of the other
strange anomalies that are found in the SCP
Foundation’s archives.
Inside the coffin with SCP-1007 is a small
metal key, and this is quite literally the
key to seeing what makes this anomaly so special.
On SCP-1007’s back between his shoulder
blades is a small keyhole.
X-ray scans of 1007 have shown that the keyhole
is just an empty socket.
It’s unconnected to anything, there’s
no internal clockwork mechanisms or other
machinery that should be able to be activated
by a key.
When the metal key that is kept in SCP-1007’s
coffin, classified as SCP-1007-1, is inserted
into the keyhole on 1007’s back and turned,
something truly incredible happens.
As the key is turned, SCP-1007 undergoes a
change unlike anything the SCP Foundation
has seen before.
With each turn of the key, the subject’s
physical age is reversed by one full year.
Foundation researchers are able to watch 1007
age in reverse in real time.
Even any decay that had set in on the corpse
is completely reversed and disappears as the
key is wound and 1007 gets younger and younger.
As the key is turned, 1007 will continue to
de-age, physically compacting and shrinking
down until it appears to have the form of
a newborn human child.
It’s unknown where the physical mass of
1007’s body goes to, since this should defy
the laws of physics, but those laws we assume
to be a bedrock of our universe’s reality
are often more of a suggestion when it comes
to anomalies the SCP Foundation deals with.
Once SCP-1007 reaches the newborn baby stage,
it will suddenly reactivate, coming to life
immediately regardless of how long it has
been dead and lying in its coffin.
Once 1007 is brought back to life, he will
go through the entire human life cycle within
a seventy-five minute period, experiencing
what looks to be approximately one year of
normal human growth and development for every
minute that passes.
That means that in the course of about sixteen
minutes, researchers will see SCP-1007 change
from a crying infant to a fully grown teenager.
As you can imagine, the subject has reported
feeling excruciating pain during these first
few minutes as his bones rapidly lengthen
and expand, and his muscles develop and change
shape dramatically.
SCP-1007 is able to watch with his young eyes
as his bones move and set themselves into
place, lengthening and widening in seconds
during growth spurts that normally take months
or years.
After about five minutes, provided his legs
have grown to the same length at the same
time, he’s usually able to prop himself
up and stand.
At around ten minutes, the pain really starts.
The bones crack and ache as they grow at their
fastest for the whole cycle.
Hair will also grow on his face and body,
and he can’t help but feel some amount of
shame and embarrassment at what’s happening
to him in front of the Foundation researchers,
who are taking copious notes.
By twenty minutes, he can hardly think due
to the pain.
At this point, he usually lies down and curls
into a ball, whispering to himself that it
will all be over soon, that the pain won’t
last forever.
After another ten minutes, he’s right.
The pain has almost stopped completely by
the thirty minute mark, but now as wrinkles
and stretch marks start to set in, a different
kind of pain reveals itself as SCP-1007 realizes
that he must watch himself die.
Forty minutes in and he starts to reflect
on his past, the life he was forced to lead
as a kind of sideshow freak, more on that
later though.
The physical decay happens faster now, warts
and moles and other marks of age appearing
on his skin.
After fifty minutes he is aware that over
half of his “life” has passed and he is
reaching the end.
His hair starts to fall out as do his teeth,
which he’s never actually been able to use
as he has never tasted food.
As the sixty minute mark comes and goes, he
begins to feel grateful for the coming end,
with the escape from pain and the rest it
would bring.
His body has become very wrinkled by this
point and is covered with age spots.
His eyes begin to cloud severely limiting
his ability to see and his hearing gets weaker
and weaker until he can’t comprehend anything
the researchers say.
At seventy five minutes it’s all over.
SCP-1007’s body expires and he dies once
again.
He will remain as a corpse until the metal
key is inserted into his back and the whole
process starts once again.
Just as there appears to be no explanation
for where the mass of SCP-1007’s body goes
as the key is wound during the reversal process,
so too is there no explanation for where the
energy needed for his rapid growth comes from.
This process should violate the First Law
of Thermodynamics, and Foundation researchers
are very curious about the underlying process.
The one constant that remains on SCP-1007’s
body is a small tattoo on his right calf,
where the words “Mr. Life and Mr. Death,
from Little Misters ® by Dr. Wondertainment”
appear.
This matches up with entry number eleven on
document SCP-909-a which lists a total of
20 “Little Misters.”
SCP-1007 was recovered by Task Force Tau-6
during a raid on a mansion in California along
with several other anomalous creatures and
objects.
The owner of the mansion claimed that he had
acquired SCP-1007 at an auction hosted by
Marshall, Carter, and Dark Ltd.
Marshall, Carter, and Dark Ltd. is a “club”
based in London, England that is famed for
collecting and selling what it would describe
as “rare and obscure” objects.
Unfortunately, this often includes various
anomalies that should be under the care of
the SCP Foundation, and the club’s mission
to provide its members with exclusive, expensive,
and rare experiences means that they’re
often in conflict with the Foundation, and
they have even been responsible for several
containment breaches.
Marshall, Carter, and Dark Ltd. continues
to be a very secretive organization, and the
name of the director and a list of its members
have so far been very difficult to obtain.
At the auction they hosted where SCP-1007
was offered for sale, there were apparently,
along with Mr. Life and Death, at least four
other “Misters” for sale though the identity
of the other buyers and which Little Misters
they may have purchased is still under investigation.
The fact that SCP-1007 has the name Mr. Life
AND Mr. Death seems to imply that he may have
originally been part of a set, though this
counterpart Little Mister has yet to be recovered
or even identified.
In interviews with SCP-1007, he has given
his own personal theory that he embodies both
names, and the designation is a reference
to the way he alternates between life and
death.
However, the possibility still remains though
that he may have a twin of sorts, and the
Foundation continues to investigate its possible
identity and location.
SCP-1007’s brief seventy five minute life
followed by a death that lasts until he is
rewound by his special key means that he is
easily contained and has been classified as
“safe.”
He is only to be activated during routine
testing and after experiencing death, he is
to be placed back into his coffin along with
the key.
In keeping with current regulations for all
anomalies that have been designated as “Misters”,
SCP-1007 is to be contained in Hall 8 of Site
13 for additional observation and study.
Now go watch SCP-3008 - Trapped in Ikea or
SCP-5000 The Suit for more explanations of
the strangest anomalies the SCP Foundation
deals with.